today's topic warden are you sir deputy
snow with these Simpson County Sheriff's
Office you got your license and
registration on you I'll let you know as
soon as you give me your ID you who you
work for there your your shirt oh come
and get more old company how long you
been there I'm just talkin Jim I see
your shirt here pro tip if has nothing
to do with this stop don't tell them
nothin
don't give him any information because
they can use that to incriminate God you
stopped are you driving 65 and you know
speed limits and I'm just wondering
what's wrong with me is it illegal to
drive under the speed limits not even
when you're on the highway the speed
limit is the speed limit is a hundred
and that's kilometres per hour so so 60
right and the a hundred and the minimum
is 60 so even if you're on the highway
you're on the highway the maximum you
can drive legally without gettin a
ticket is a hundred the maximum is a
hundred the minimum is 16
only in that instance if you're driving
if you're on the highway and you're
driving 50 they're gonna stop you and
you're gonna be like what are you doing
because you're being dangerous because
of the flow okay other than that if it's
70 and I'm driving 65 that's not illegal
but I've been stopped because of that
anything is suspicious what are you why
are you not driving
it's just boy and here they change the
way they they stop you first it was like
wow you know oh it's a routine checked
it was a routine check and then we
started making some noise because no
what is all these routine checks
nobody gets with the routine see naughty
change it they stopped me because the
car is under my wife's name while you
know the vehicle doesn't match the
driver really you could you tell you're
telling me that's just stopping
everybody
that it doesn't match right here with
you okay
other than I mean you okay I'm just
checking on you that's all I'm doing
okay
you good I'm great I'm doing better than
I deserve you know where are you coming
from now and this is standard when I get
stopped this is standard so all the
white people that are watching me like
yo what is going this is standard that's
how they act and they act up with the
ask a bunch of questions like that
its standard leave me I some point he
made me get out of my cart and search my
car three top cars so imagine that
you're going somewhere okay you're on
your way somewhere striving to subpoena
me because you got timing alright but
every time you drive in a month five
times a month this is what you go
through and it's not just hey can I let
me see your license registration I'll be
back it's all them dumb ass questions
every time at some point you're gonna
get pissed off at some point you're
gonna be like you what is going what is
that that's why we're pissed off yeah
but you have to answer questions every
time we drive can I be honest with you
bro that's why I love living in this
city because there's so much good public
transport I can take I can avoid a lot
of that bull I don't need a car living
here I don't need a car living anywhere
in this area your family's not here my
family lives out of town my fat my
sister lives 30 minutes out of here yes
35 minutes out of here my mom lives 30
minutes out of here
my wife says people they live on and now
in 45 minutes I got I got a wife I got a
drive and I got like contracts here and
there and everything so I'm working
around this and when I was a bouncer I
was working in the city so I have to
drive the transport not so good at night
right so every time you drive is these
questions like you did something and
this is not hearsay and I won and the
men didn't do anything illegal
even according to the office let's put
that in context and then
all these questions where do you work at
where are you going where are you coming
from what is going on are you doing okay
are you good are you we didn't do
anything you shouldn't be mad
listen five times a month is a lot and
eventually what happened it takes a toll
on you
and the thing that happens as well as
I'm going places and if I get late
I can't always sell to the people yeah
got stopped again they're gonna look at
you funny like the people that don't get
stopped and don't understand what is
going on they're like oh he got he got
stopped again so he must do something
stop and that is not the case go throw
that word office understand the relation
to the traffic stop I'm just trying to
figure out where you're coming from
where you're going mess like that I have
to identify where I'm traveling to worry
about that but this is ridiculous man
I'm tired of it every time I come down
every time I come back and then I could
tell you jump behind me like right you
tripping you tripping my [ __ ] like you
tripping dog what could you possibly I
brought me a ticket for warning for what
because he was talking they don't like
when you talk they don't like when you
talk back they don't like when you reply
they don't like they don't like when you
when you when you say something you when
you refute what they're saying because
they're making no sense
they hate that so they will try to give
you a ticket for whatever is the ego
talking they love to do that they
absolutely love to do that when you
start talking and you prove them wrong
on something they hate that when the
camera when the cameras rolling they
hate that but I have to have some proof
it's my safety they
when you talk back to them they hate it
they hate all of that so yeah they're
gonna give you a warning absolutely no
court date no fine that's my thirties
paper waiting when you get to the house
all right have a good day all right the
warning for sir we're traveling under
the speed limit okay
traveling is what you say is kind of
suspicious to travel under the speed
limit and they do that they drop that in
the leaf because they can this is just
normal to me that's what they do that is
just really what they do so I'm not
really surprised about this none of it
but I just I want to play I wanna I want
you to see this video just so that
people that don't understand the
perspective and why we're so pissed off
about this is it's time-consuming and
now he has a warning the understand what
that happens no he doesn't have to go to
court no he doesn't have to pay any
tickets he doesn't have to pay any fine
or anything like that he doesn't but
that is on record and depending on the
city where you are that record can last
between a week and three so whenever I'm
driving they other cops are ringing the
plate and they see there's a warning
they actually see that there's a warning
depending on where you at it's not just
it's just it raises more suspicion
so whenever like you drive five or QT
under the speed limit they're gonna be
like oh you know what
and something wrong with this that it
adds more suspicion to whatever he's
doing when there's no suspicion at all
and whenever they drive and they know
that wrong they skedaddled real quick
because they know they're wrong they
know they ain't got nothing to do listen
that's what happens this is the norm of
what we go through the number of
questions that we have like that is the
norm the absolute norm so imagine I'm
getting stopped because I didn't do
nothing and I'm getting asked all these
questions every time I'm getting stopped
and I'm getting stopped sometimes five
times a month five times a month people
don't understand it's like I
sometimes I got stuck with other people
in my car and they start recording like
why are you recording like you know
couple let me do me
people don't know they don't under they
don't understand the extent of it
but that that is the norm and actually
you know what I'm gonna say something a
bit tubby that police officer had you
know he was questions would have been
done about it
but he didn't have extra attitude some
of you cops have that extra extra
attitude when you go because you know
what you're doing you know what you're
doing you know what you're doing you
know it's gonna get people IRA and you
do that you keep doing that you know
you're wrong you damn well know you're
wrong and that's why I have a problem
which are your partner ain't gonna say
he doesn't say nothing ever what are you
gonna say something when he's that in
the car
listen the warning is already made the
warning is already put on the car and on
the license plate
the damage is done I'm already late it's
done if you say something in your car
it's done I don't care he's not gonna
care either call him on the spot when
they're about to stop you that's what
you should talk and say something about
it that's why I hate this that's just
normal
that's just the norm that ain't nothing
so you have to understand what it is and
what we call to win this is what it is
[Music]
and before any of you come out and say
oh why you guys bring up racing this
listen where we live there's a study
that came out and it proved the fact
that officers stopped African black
people at much higher rates than they do
whites for traffic stops when no ticket
is given this is not here say these are
the police's own studies they've
acknowledged this so for you to be
they're like well it's not a real thing
no it's a thing this kind of bias does
exist they saw this dude in that car and
they made that choice for driving under
the speed limit
not-not-not tremendously under the speed
limit five-five under the speed limit if
you don't get the [ __ ] out of here with
your [ __ ]